Taylor Swift
the singer with a big reputation in the
music industry is according to Forbes
worth an estimated 570 million dollars
and with era's forecast to become the
highest grossing tour of all time the
singer could considerably add to her net
worth
so how did she get here
53 of the adults in the United States
considered themselves to be Taylor Swift
fans and 16 percent considered
themselves to be AVID swifties for Swift
that translates into record sales record
breaking record sales her 10th studio
album midnights released in October 2022
sold 1.6 million albums in its first
week according to Universal music that
makes her the one and only artist to
ever have five albums sell over 1
million copies in its first week the
Resurgence of vinyl records has also
played a role in 2022 vinyls outsold CDs
for the first time since 1987. Taylor's
album midnights sold 575
000 vinyls in its first week a typical
stream generates well under a penny in
revenue from the streaming service that
the stream originates on somewhere
somewhere between a quarter and three
quarters of a penny for all Royal tours
and all participants in that income
stream when you sell a vinyl record
today which at retail costs 20 to 30
dollars well you can imagine that the
numbers are much better on a per unit
basis certainly than than a stream still
streaming has significantly contributed
to Taylor's wealth according to
Universal the singer has 36 points
billion combined streams of her music
but there was a time when streaming
services and Taylor were on Rocky ground
from 2014 to 2017 Swift boycotted
Spotify removing all her music from the
platform in 2015 Swift wrote an open
letter to Apple objecting to the
company's decision to not pay artists
streaming royalties during the
three-month Apple music trial period
Apple to their credit came back and said
you're right we've changed our mind
about this and we will pay artists for
the use of music during the trial period
when her album midnights released it
became spotify's most streamed album in
a single day and also broke the record
for the most streamed artist in a single
day on Spotify money from music streams
and sales doesn't just go to the artist
in 2022 Swift generated close to three
percent of universal music's annual
revenue or 230 million dollars in sales
for the biggest music label in the world
according to JP Morgan in every piece of
music that you hear here there are two
copyrights involved the copyright and
the underlying musical composition the
song itself that's where songwriters and
music Publishers live once the song is
made into a sound recording that's
usually where the record company and the
performer live typically record labels
own the masters of a song or the
original recording that means the labels
keep the fee for master recording use
every time a song is streamed performed
on TV or played in a movie in 2019
Scooter Braun managing Ithaca Holdings
bought Big Machine Label Group which
owned the Masters to her recordings he
then spun off her Masters after the
catalog sale had happened Taylor would
still be a royalty participant as the
artist who made the records but the vast
majority of that income would be going
to the owner of the catalog Ithaca
Holdings in 2018 Swift revealed on
Instagram that she signed with Republic
records a label Under Universal Music
group as part of the deal Swift said she
would own her future Master recordings
and her contract with her previous home
Big Machine Label group allowed her to
re-record her old songs in most
traditional artist agreements most
artists are barred for a really long
period of time from re-recording their
original Works Taylor as her career
became the Fantastic Juggernaut that it
did gained a tremendous amount of
Leverage in the deals that she was able
to make while still on big machine I'm
not sure if the provisions allowed for
her to re-record within a very short
period of time after a sale or not but
we do know that the period was very
truncated much more than it normally is
for the conventional artist deal so far
Swift has re-released her albums
fearless and read as Taylor's version
both making it to the top of Billboard
charts and selling more album units in
the first week than their original
releases for any sales of these Swift
received leaves the artist and master
share of the song Revenue it was to
Taylor's benefit to be able to maximize
her income and give the fans you know
new versions of the songs that they knew
and loved so much and have the income
come directly to her or to the
administrators who are managing the new
records for her then of course there are
Taylor Swift's tour works
[Music]
when the Taylor tour went on sale it
broke the internet and it broke
Ticketmaster's system there are very few
artists in the world who face virtually
infinite demand for seats to their
concerts at almost any price when
Ticketmaster put the Taylor Swift tour
on sale essentially there were three and
a half billion requests for one and a
half million seats tours are a huge
Money Maker for artists 85 or 90 or more
of the face value of the ticket goes to
pay the artist but not just the artists
themselves I mean to put a big tour on
the road is really expensive so it pays
for the artist in everyone in the
artist's Camp from everybody you see on
stage to the people who move the
equipment in and out to the people who
operate the sound and lights to the
people who drive the trucks and fly the
planes around and negotiate the deal but
overwhelmingly most of what the ticket
price goes to is to pay for the artist
and the eras tour could gross 728
million dollars according to concert
data tracker pollstar which also
predicts that the tour could set the
record for the highest grossing tour in
a calendar year so what keeps Taylor
Swift fans in love with her music
hundreds of millions of people around
the world relate to her music in a in a
powerful and profound and utterly
relatable way we're talking about
a music Creator and performer
whose music changes the lives of the
people who relate so closely to it that
makes Taylor utterly unique in the
constellation of Music Makers well-known
and less well-known over the last 10
years in particular
[Music]